[Music]
the nightmare begins what's up everybody
since that doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness trailer dropped
this past super bowl sunday there's been
another short trailer released with even
more never before seen footage surely
meant to get the people talking and
that's exactly what the internet is
doing and we love it so right now we're
gonna get into some of our favorite
theories about what exactly is going on
in doctor strange and the multiverse of
madness this is e.t canada's nerdlift i
never
meant for any of this
to happen first of all let's talk about
the many variants of dr strange we might
be getting in this movie who if they
team up will form what i like to call
the sorcerer supreme team
which now that i'm hearing it out loud
sounds a lot darker than i thought you
got the good old-fashioned doctor
strange that we all know and love but of
course you got this guy strange supreme
who was first introduced in marvel's
what if animated series the doctor
strange who was corrupted by power after
a tragic loss defender strange makes his
first on-screen appearance in the new
short trailer that we just got he's got
slick back hair a new outfit and i hope
it's not just like a costume change from
the third act of the movie i really hope
that's another doctor strange because i
want this whole you know sorcerer
supreme team thing to work and finally
you've got this handsome fellow who
could be strange supreme even further
corrupted by all the demons and monsters
and whatnot that he's absorbed but a
more interesting theory to me
is that if this is in fact
zombie doctor strange from marvel
zombies
things just got out of hand well aside
from those variants of himself who could
dr strange be teaming up with this
go-around well we know he's got wong his
best friend and basically the ultimate
hero of this phase of the mcu if you're
asking me
also if you saw all of wand division you
know that stephen strange went to go
talk to wanda maximoff about the
multiverse but if this trailer is
anything to go by it doesn't really seem
like the two
are on best terms
i do it i become the enemy
it doesn't seem faint a new face you
might not recognize is america chavez
aka miss america who can literally kick
open doors to new dimensions which you
know fits the theme in the movie very
well and then there's this fiery figure
that all of the internet has been
speculating about who could it be it
looked to me right away off the top like
a version of captain marvel that we
haven't seen before and i'm hoping that
us as a collective on the internet are
correct when we say that this is
actually monica rambo
as the new captain marvel or a version
of captain mark
so who are the villains well as we
mentioned before wanda doesn't seem to
be seeing eye to eye with steven this go
around clearly still mourning the loss
of her family and questioning this whole
superhero thing as for the doctor
strange variants truthfully any of them
could be friend or foe so you never
really know
we do see the return of og doctor
strange nemesis baron mordo and we get
an even better look at the multiversal
reality conquering near omnipotent and
super gross schuma giraffe or maybe it
actually is gargantos now although all
of that is very exciting the moment from
the trailers that everyone is talking
about
is right here
we should tell him the truth yes that is
the unmistakable voice of ralph boner
just kidding no patrick stewart who
could only be playing professor x here
right which means many things number one
mutants finally showing up at the mcu
and number two
this whole sequence with these figures
seated in front of doctor strange that
is the illuminati now for those of you
that don't know the illuminati in marvel
is a secret cabal of superheroes that
make all the big decisions in the comics
they include doctor strange professor x
black bolt iron man namor and mr
fantastic but if you look closely
there's also like a hooded figure with a
cape
could that be dr doom i don't know see
this is this is why these trailers are
amazing this gets everyone talking we
get the theories going and i know all
you out there are really excited so
you've seen the trailers let me know
what you think what are your favorite
theories about what is going on in
doctor strange and the multiverse of
madness let's talk about it in the
comments below and i'll see you here
next time